after agent feilow's death we were able
to get our hands on a laptop at camp
white oak
on closer inspection it is found to
contain six encrypted files called
insurance policy
councils managed to decrypt three of
them and the information exposed so far
changes things
quite considerably
[Music]
[Music]
i know we haven't worked together for
very long
but i trust you
kelso that's funny
you remind me a lot of my sister
heather
i think you would have liked her
probably a lot more than you like me
maybe that's why i couldn't tell you
i knew you would have tried to help
or the same in that way
there are too many people who need you
who count on you
[ __ ]
even rhodes loves you and he hates
everybody
once you got to new york it was clear
they didn't need me anymore but there
was something else happening
another threat was building and i had to
figure out what it was before it was too
late
and i did it
i figured it out
i know what's coming kelso and i know
how to stop it
i just have to secure the button then we
can fight it together
we're family now
we bonded fighting this war kelso you're
the only sister i have left
i couldn't tell you what i was planning
i needed you angry at me to keep my
cover
i'm sorry
i know i hurt you
but i couldn't find another way to do
this
please know it only went down this way
because the division couldn't afford to
lose you too
they need a leader
then you're the only one i trust
i see this comms is confirming two
things firstly something i've talked
about for a long time that fay wasn't
really rogue that she was undercover the
most obvious piece being the messages
she left with benitez and rhodes
apologizing for what she was about to do
secondly the writers seem to be trying
to paint kelso in a bitter light i see
you lauren stone trying to stop me
swaying the community in the wrong
direction
by the way i love your work lady
i've been saying for years that i don't
trust her and don't get me wrong she
still irks me to a certain point though
this could be my own life experience
bias coming through kelso reminds me so
disturbingly much of an old girlfriend
of mine from many years ago who
legitimately still scares the crap out
of me like that crazy check would have
cut me and warned my skin as a onesie i
swear though to be fair as a young fella
i probably would have more than deserved
it anyway the message is clear and i
think this is a direct response to the
speculation going on around the
community
kelso is well and truly one of the good
guys or at least this is what they'd
like us to think going forward
faye talks to her with fondness and even
compares her to her sister
she wants to do better by kelso and not
let history repeat itself
where she feels she failed her sister
she wants to protect kelso and keep her
safe
she also seemed quite aware of what a
betrayal might possibly do to the
division ranks and she believed they
still needed someone strong on their
side to keep them inspired and focused
in the right direction and kalsa was the
only one who she believed could do that
fading goes on to talk about another
threat that was building and that she
had figured out what it was that she
knows what to do that needs to secure
the button
as we talked about in the last video
this button is most likely to be the
nuclear football the briefcase that
contains the president's authentication
codes for initiating a nuclear strike
we know that faye was successful in
taking down president ellis but where is
the nuclear football now did she manage
to grab this and hide it somewhere or is
it now with the black tusk
i hear your boy schaefer's having
trouble handling some former
subordinates of mine schaefer isn't the
problem cal does he have trouble taking
orders from a woman not at all
he's oddly one of the good ones
he has never questioned my authority
your agents are not team players they
were never supposed to be which is fine
when you need an assassin but when
you're nation rebuilding you need to
have a modicum of interpersonal skills
are you saying they're no longer a good
fit
and may have trouble staying on mission
they're rogues cal by your own
definition they are off mission you need
me to send the cleanup crew i don't know
if it has come to that yet
but we could use some additional support
shaffer can't be everywhere at once
these agents are all over the map dc new
york he goes to help one and he fails
the other
we need someone who is mobile
under the radar
and can gain access and assess whether
or not it is worth continuing to support
agent lau's operation do you trust her
natalia no
but she also hasn't given me a reason
not to other than being a rogue
but i prefer to not let labels define a
person's character
she will show me who she really is in
time
from what i can tell she's loyal to a
fault dedicated community minded
and selfless
those are traits that can be wonderful
or a liability
just depends on how fixed or malleable
she is from what i remember from her
assessment
she can get fixated and i'm fairly
certain her personality assessment was
lawful good
which is appropriate for your
organization as long as she feels her
work leans toward justice we're trying
to save the american dream
what could be more just than that
here we are introduced to calvin mcmanus
a name we previously heard about in
alice's memoirs
the way he talks with natalia appears
that they don't necessarily just work
together but he holds more of a position
of prominence over her but what i found
interesting here was the mention of
former subordinates
further into the columns it's clear that
they're talking about barden schaefer's
operation where he was teamed up with a
bunch of rogues that faye had put him in
contact with
this implies that mcmanus is reasonably
high up within the government or
potentially within the shd
but this doesn't make complete sense the
word subordinates means that these
rogues were previously under his
authority or control and as we well know
the division only answers to the
president
officially according to the u.s federal
government the strategic homeland
division is formally listed as part of
the department of homeland security
however they report directly to the
president of the united states
the shd is led by a board of directors
there isn't a single centralized
facility that everything is run through
because the shd has been put in place as
a unit that activates in time of
catastrophic emergency
having a single headquarters would lead
them vulnerable to attack or disaster of
some kind
instead the rule of three is applied
the division hq is located in three
identical bunker facilities called cores
each core is independently operated and
managed by a director with a seat on the
board these facilities are located
through the center of the country in
south dakota kansas and texas
maybe mcmanus is part of the shd's board
of directors
[Music]
mcmanus talks about the rogue agents not
really being trained to work as a team
with an army like the black tusk and
this is true they're meant to be
autonomous to be able to continue their
work with minimal to no direction or
leadership in case these two have fallen
again this just confirms that he is
somewhere in a position of prominence in
the government because only a handful of
people were privy to information around
the division
next he suggests sending in a cleanup
crew and while natalya declines this she
still requests support as schaefer can't
be everywhere at once
she would prefer someone who is mobile
under the radar and can gain access and
assess whether or not it's worth
continuing to support agent lau's
operation
this is interesting because if we go
back to the shaffer manhunt where he was
struggling to get these rogues in line
there was a hunter who was involved
he kept popping up when coming up
against each rogue agent this hunter
wasn't just fighting the division agents
he was attacking the rogue targets too
it could have been that the hunter had
assessed the situation and decided that
the rogue's part in this operation had
been lost or completed so had to be
eliminated before the division was able
to capture and interrogate any
information out of them
joke was on him though we kill
everything well apart from shaffer of
course actually probably the only reason
we were able to take him alive was
because we had already disposed of the
hunter by then
so if this is true mcmanus is the one
behind the hunters
this potentially makes them american
but if a single hunter was just support
what is a cleanup crew
would there just be a whole bunch of
hunters or something else
the only other thing that i wanted to
talk about with this is where they
mentioned phase operation
what is it that they thought she was
doing i mean we know what she was
actually doing under her own agenda but
what was she supposed to be doing for
them was it just a test where the
outcome would decide whether to bring
her further into this circle and before
she could get there we took her out
i get the feeling that natalia may
actually believe what they're doing is
right for the country
but mcmanus
nothing seems right about him
is it possible that natalia is yet
another individual in the division
universe that is having his strings
pulled by someone else
i had hoped to release all three parts
in this video but i keep going back to
the third one and rewriting it this one
is particularly interesting and has
ended up taking a little longer than i'd
planned but i'll have it out soon
as you'll have noticed from the opening
scene in the video we can already see
the name of the next three parts tactics
cuts and rendezvous
if the ones we've seen so far are
anything to go by these are looking to
get progressively more interesting as we
get through them and i'm a little
excited to say the least
anyway i hope you've enjoyed the video
and i'll catch you soon in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]